notre actualité du jour c'est ce projet
un peu fou en apparence qui est celui du
président de la république de relancer
la réforme des retraites sujet clivant
seelandais à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle la nouvelle halle
emmanuel macron hésite mais peut-être
qu'il se dit que c'est une façon de
montrer aux électeurs de droite qui n'a
pas renoncé à transformer le pays
écouter celui qui défend plutôt cette
idée c'est gabriel atta le porte parole
du gouvernement alors tendez bien
l'oreille parce que comme toujours qui a
dû en même temps il dit c'est peut-être
pas le bon moment
mais finalement il faudrait peut-être
mieux pas attendre dix mois parce que ce
serait du temps perdu
ce qui est sur la table c'est de faire
une réforme des retraites
en intégrant notamment le fait qu'il
faut travailler plus longtemps
voilà ce qui est sur la table après il
ya des questions de modalités et il ya
une question de calendrier pour nous la
question n'est pas de savoir s'il faut
faire une réforme des retraites mais
quand il faut la faire et si la france
se met sur pause parce qu'à une élection
présidentielle pendant dix mois
on va perdre du temps valence est
russell
alors voilà ceux qui sont favorables les
contres ce sont comme on pouvait s'y
attendre les syndicats pas seulement les
syndicats salariés d'ailleurs parce que
même le medef trouve que c'est pas le
bon moment et qu'il faut mieux attendre
l'élection présidentielle mais voici
l'avis pas complètement inattendu disons
le de philippe martinez le patron de la
cgt
l'unanimité des syndicats est contre le
fait qu' on reparle réforme des
retraites dans la période il dit à
d'autres priorités ça le message qu'on
va lui faire passer et un dernier point
de vue plus surprenant car c'est celui
d'un proche des manuels macron l'un des
piliers de sa majorité françois bayrou
le patron du modem lui trouve que c'est
pas la peine de provoquer les
populations avant l'élection je pense
que la période électorale n'est pas
favorable pour faire passer à la va vite
une réforme
moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'une réforme
difficile comme la réforme des retraites
il n'y avait qu'un moyen de la faire
passer sans bloquer le pays
c'est de dire que au terme de sa
préparation
c'est les français qui choisiraient donc
qui a réouvert le rire ma référente à
est-ce qu'il est urgent d'attendre
nicolas baverez si vous étiez le
le conseiller spécial d'emmanuel macron
que lui que préconiseriez-vous alors
d'abord il ya parmi les rares bonnes
nouvelles dans ce pays il ya le fait que
je ne suis pas le conseiller spécial bas
coûts et donc comme moi ça ça lui sera
salut sera évitée il omet il omet assez
bien préservés pour répondre à la
question est la première chose c'est que
il faut pas faire de tactique politique
avec un thème comme les retraites c'est
un des piliers de notre contrat social
c'est beaucoup d'argent et donc soit là
tout ceci on veut jouer à la petite
politique avec on est certain d'aller
devant des déboires majeur alors
aujourd'hui il ya un problème massif des
finances publiques
donc on a des déficits qui sont hors de
contrôle qui augmente d'ailleurs en 2021
ce qui est aberrant 9 4% du ppi ben on a
une dette de 118% du pipe ça fait
quarante et un mille euros par français
et c'est vrai qu'un des curseurs
importance ce sont les retraites alors
est ce que c'est le bon moment je ne le
pense pas pour deux raisons d'abord d'un
point de vue économique pour moi la
priorité c'est vraiment la reprise
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est si on
doit faire des choses c'est sur la
production et notamment
il faut sortir de cette aberration
qu'aujourd'hui alors qu'on a beaucoup de
pouvoir d'achat on a une production
nationale qui est freiné parce qu on est
en pénurie d'emplois et qu'on a des
goulots d'étranglement un peu partout la
priorité aujourd'hui pour la france
à court terme c'est de retrouver le plus
possible son niveau de production de fin
2019 et donc
intéressons nous à l'emploi à
l'investissement et pour une fois vous
aussi vous voulez qu'on s'occupe
toujours de redistribution jamais de
production c'est la production et je
finirai en disant que le et là le fait
que c'est assez rare de voir que
françois bayrou est monsieur martinez le
patron de la cgt sont à peu près sur la
même ligne et est en fait il se trouve
que c'est peut-être la bonne pourquoi
parce que si cela encore vouloir faire
une rentrée une réforme à la va vite sur
quelque chose comme ça je pense que ça
n'a pas de sens
on voit aujourd'hui qu'on a un énorme
problème de redistribution mais aussi d'
équilibre entre les générations est donc
ce qu'il faut c'est pas faire la réforme
des retraites a minima pour dire qu'on
l'a fait s'est il faut aujourd'hui
arriver à négocier un nouveau contrat
économique et social un nouveau pacte
économique et social entre les citoyens
français c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut faire à la va vite et pour le coup
ça c'est un vrai thème de l'élection
présidentielle donc moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui pour le court terme et
dieu sait qu'en matière de production il
ya des réformes à faire si on veut en
faire il ya plein de choses à imaginer
mais mettons l'accent là dessus et le
thème des retraites doit être intégrée à
un grand débat sur qu'est-ce qu'on
trouve comme pacte économique et social
pour remettre l'économie française
d'aplomb et l'adapter au xxième siècle
tout en gardant notre modèle de
solidarité
et bien c'est dommage que nicolas
baverez soit pas le conseiller spécial
d'emmanuel maquereau ou même le
conseiller spécial d'un certain nombre
de candidates droite je partage tout ce
qui a été dit je trouve effectivement
vous avez parfaitement raison de mettre
l'accent sur la production et l'emploi
il faut
si on veut résoudre à long terme le
problème des retraites il va falloir
résoudre d'abord le problème de la
croissance et même mettre un certain
nombre de français au travail je crois
que s'il faut travailler plus sans doute
mais surtout il faut pour travailler
plus il faut avoir moins de chemin au
moins de revenus d'assistance et je
crois que si on fait ça ensuite on
pourra éventuellement négocier un
allongement du temps de travail mais ce
sera beaucoup mieux compris et surtout
ce sera dans un horizon de redressement
du pays et là on voit bien que majorité
après majorité d'ailleurs qu'elle soit
de gauche de droite ou du centre
bon nous propose d'allonger un peu le
temps de travail mais c'est pas une
manière effectivement de redresser leur
audace et le pays de retrouver l'emploi
et la croissance et je suis d'accord
avec vous le problème majeur de la
france c'est une balance commerciale qui
est totalement déficitaire dit qu'il
faut se remettre à produire à exporter à
travailler et l'enjeu est effectivement
n'est pas de faire une réforme des
retraites
2 qui sera de toute manière
voilà paramétrique et donc systémique et
qui ne convaincra personne et qui ne
donnera pas de raison au pays donc voilà
on voit pourquoi manuellement qu'on le
fait le fait pour des raisons de
tactique politique d'abord ce qui veut
séduire une certaine partie de la droite
où conserver une certaine partie sonnée
et aura les retraités ans principalement
ceux qui sont les plus favorables à
cette réforme des retraites qui pourtant
ont eux profité retraite à 60 ans est
pas connu la précarité de l'emploi donc
donc il s'agit de consolider cet
électorat-là de faire plaisir à certains
électorat de droite ou composé de deux
cadeaux aisée pour être présent au
second tour est de ne pas perdre
il a une image de réformateur on sait
pas exactement pourquoi parce qu'il n'a
pas fait tellement de réformes dans son
quinquennat mais ça ne lui permettrait
de conserver cette cette image là
ensuite je pense qu'il le fait pour une
deuxième raison il veut envoyer des
signaux à l'europe qui fait marcher la
planche à billets auraient ce moment et
montrer que la france reste un pays
sérieux qui a l'intention de réformer
mais voilà moi je pense que
effectivement c'est pas à nos raisons
anne horizons pour le pays et vous avez
raison
l'horizon pour le pays c'est de le ré
industrialiser de produire de nouveaux
effectivement de faire ça plus
intelligent de faire ce pacte entre les
générations
parce que je disais tout à l'heure qu'il
y avait effectivement un conflit entre
les retraités et les actifs qui n'ont
pas forcément le même point de vue sur
l'europe les retraites et je pense
notamment aux classes populaires et
moyennes
finalement bénéficié assez peu du modèle
social français
il bénéficiait de deux choses ce cas un
système de santé qui était réputé bon on
a vu qu'il s'était effondré avec le co
lead et éventuellement de pouvoir partir
à la retraite après une longue vie de
travail
je pense que si on veut faire des
économies et des économies à faire avant
ailleurs que de les faire encore une
fois sur le dos des classes populaires
et moyennes qui travaillent et puis je
note qu'on veut
toujours rallonger le temps de travail
pourquoi pas mais à ce moment là faut
peut-être baisser le taux de cotisation
jusqu'en cotisent
encore une fois je ne comprends pas où
va l'argent je crois que c'est le c'est
la question centrale
certes il ya beaucoup de déficit c'est
inacceptable mais aussi un pays qui
cotisent énormément qui paye énormément
d'impôts donc il ya un moment donné va
falloir réfléchir à comment on gère et à
qui on donne l'argent quelles sont les
priorités du pays peut-être que c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on peut être tellement
de cotisation c'est comment on travaille
moi en tant que les autres ben forcément
pour équilibrer le système des retraites
et encore on y arrive même pas on est
obligé de cotiser plus alors moi je dois
dire que toutes mes certitudes
s'effondre parce que si même nicolas
baverez l'homme le plus rigoureux des
royaumes pas d'urgence on verra ça
l'année prochaine
j'entends vos arguments quand même mais
c'est vrai quand même je manque un peu
ébranlé non mais genre de jeu par
ailleurs enfin ce qui était dit on à un
niveau de dépenses publiques extravagant
dans ce pays puisque c'est 61% du pib'
donc ce qui veut dire que quand on élève
les neuf points de déficit
on a aussi un niveau de de recettes
publiques extravagant puisque ça fait 61
- 9
donc ça fait cinquante deux pour cent ce
qui est énorme
donc on est ça veut pas dire qu'ils
aient pas d'économies à faire en temps
des mois bien le grand paradoxe
et c'est là où je crois que le quoi
qu'il en coûte effectivement être venu
là encore une stratégie électorale parce
qu'on essaye de déverser de la dette
publique finalement pour d'une certaine
manière faire un pont et d'une certaine
manière a acheté cette élection
présidentielle et aujourd'hui on devrait
sortir beaucoup plus vite des aides
c'est quand même pas normal qu'on ait
2,3 millions de gens en chômage partiel
indemnisé très largement qui ne sont pas
formés en plus alors que et qu'en même
temps on est une pénurie d'emploi de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
d'emploi avec des secteurs entiers qui
sont des secteurs importants et qui ne
peuvent pas fournir et du coup on fait
appel aux importations en partie
pourquoi
donc c'est la priorité mais je pense que
c'est vraiment ça là c'est ça la
priorité oui alors heureusement il nous
reste les internautes du figaro pour me
conforter un peu dans ma volonté de
réformer sans tarder ce pays
macron emmanuel mâcon doit-il engager la
réforme des retraites avant la
présidentielle il ya une majorité une
petite majorité quand même un mec qui
considère que oui alors c'est à la fois
l'objet de la question du jour dans le
figaro et
donc là voilà ça c'est la réponse à la
question du jour oui à 54,16 % les
réactions en revanche considèrent que
c'est peut-être pas forcément l'idée du
siècle c'est une pure folie un suicide
électoral pour macro nous dit kris kross
la réforme des retraites doit être
abandonnée surenchérit micheline on
n'est pas sorti du virus et en plus ça
va relancer les manifestations c'est
vrai les manifestations c'est peut-être
pas bon pour la pandémie parce que ça
peut faire circuler le virus delta le
variant delta chaoui libre il faut faire
un consensus national sur la réforme des
retraites et impliquer tout le monde et
aussi donner les explications avec une
très grande pédagogie et puis encore un
point de vue celui de nicole qui estime
que vouloir faire passer cette réforme
avant la fin du mandat d' emmanuel
macron risque de faire une réforme
bâclée et cet argument nicolas baverez
qui est employée régulièrement par bruno
le maire qui lui épouse plutôt pour une
une début de réforme qui consiste à dire
il faut envoyer des signaux aux marchés
financiers pour montrer que
on va quand même resserrer un peu les
boulons parce que sinon ils vont prendre
peur et les taux d'intérêt augmenteront
poule c bah si mais que le ministre des
finances le ministre du budget fassent
leur boulot c'est eux qui sont à la tête
d'un déficit 9 4% du pip qui est plus
élevé en 2021 qu'en 2020 ce qui est
complètement anormal et c'est eux qui
sont en train de lâcher la bride parce
que sous prétexte que 2022 va être une
année présidentielle
donc grosso modo il faut être clair la
dette supplémentaires en deux ans en
passant de 98 à 118 % du pib
on en a pris il faudra 67 ans pour
revenir au niveau d'endettement de la
fin 2019
donc ces mêmes gens nous en ont mis pour
67 ans de remboursement donc maintenant
qu'ils fassent leur métier et de fait je
pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de de
dépenses qui devraient être sérieusement
remise en question
grosso modo on a mis on a injecté deux
fois plus que les pertes d'activité et
donc en réalité on a fait de la
politique pour les clientèles pour les
clientes aisées lecteurs donc maintenant
il faut que la france se remettent au
travail c'est vraiment ça la priorité
est très franchement pour les marchés
financiers pour comme pour tout
économistes la croissance potentielle
elle est beaucoup plus importante que
les retraites pourquoi parce que la
soutenabilité de la dette
c'est très clair c'est à dire qu' il
faut que la croissance nominale c'est à
dire croissanceplus inflation ça soit
supérieur aux taux d'intérêt et donc on
sait que les taux d'intérêt sont en
train de remonter
le problème c'est que la croissance de
la france elle est pour l'instant la
croissance potentielle est inférieure à
1%
donc la meilleure manière d'éviter un
problème sur la dette c'est d'augmenter
la croissance on est à l'honneur
absolument d'accord là dessus et
j'ajouterais que les marchés financiers
sont plus intelligents que ce que l'on
peut penser
la réponse de tous les gouvernements
encore une fois pour rassurer les
marchés financiers mais ça fait quinze
ans que ça dure si on va faire une
réforme paramétrique des retraites je
pense que les marchés financiers s'il ya
une vraie stratégie de relance du pays
un horizon de croissance ils le
comprendront bien et ils monteront pas
les taux d'intérêt donc aux politiques
de faire preuve d'imagination
effectivement de bonnes gestions
d'accord avec vous même si vous même ne
lèverait pas l'idée chère alexandre que
si on vit de plus en plus longtemps et
c'est heureux il faut qu'on travaille un
petit peu plus qu'on ne pourra pas
indéfiniment
travailler trois grandes banques les
autres européens en face à celle des
très courts mais les gens mais tout le
monde est d'accord là dessus mais c'est
un problème de priorité mais j'ai
compris à la france ça n'est pas c'est
important en fait il ya deux choses il
ya la démographie et ensuite il ya les
écarts notamment entre le public et le
privé sans même des régimes spéciaux
c'est ça le problème des retraites qui
n'est pas très content même dans le
groupe de la démographie qui n'est pas
au mieux
vu le taux de chômage si on revenait au
plein emploi
le déficit serait quand même en partie
comblé que ça rassure ça doit être une
priorité après moi je suis pas contre
l'allongement du ce sujet vous passionne
mais j'en ai un autre à